président le prix a payé face au
terrorisme troième volet de la série
réalisée par Pauline palier est signé
Michel Kota et Patrice duamel qui nous
font le plaisir d'être avec nous encore
une fois malheureusement on n'imaginait
pas et vous non plus lorsque vous avez
réalisé ce film que sa diffusion
s'inscrirait dans une actualité à
nouveau marquée par le terrorisme cela
donnera peut-être encore plus de de
force et de poids à nos échange Michel
cotta bienvenue journaliste politique
écrivaine je rappelle que vous venez de
publier vos mémoires ma 5e chez Bouin
édition Patrice duamel bienvenue à vous
également journaliste politique je
précise pour le plaisir que le précédent
opus de votre série documentaire a reçu
le Prix du public lors du Festival de la
fiction du documentaire politique
Dominique réier est également avec nous
bienvenue politologue directeur général
de Fondapol la Fondation pour
l'innovation politique parmi les
nombreuses études que vous avez publié
il y a celle-ci les attentats islamistes
dans le monde et Jérôme cordelier
bienvenue à vous également rédacteur en
chef au point le point partenaire de
cette émission je rappelle également que
vous venez de publier après la nuit ces
chrétiens qui ont reconstruit la France
et l'Europe merci à tous les quatre
d'être ici on vient de voir différents
président et ministres qui ont eu à
gérer qui ont eu à gérer pardon des
attentats terroristes sur le sol
français Michel cota qui vous a le plus
marqué dans sa gestion de l'attentat
terroriste sur son sol je pense à au
sfroid de de Jacques chira qui est
marquant dans votre film ou à l'empathie
de François Hollande qui vous a le plus
marqué ce qui me frappe c'est qu'ils ont
tous réagi avec leur tempérament oui euh
et pas alors on voit Sarkozi débordant
d'énergie à la fois se disant mais
comment on peut consoler les gens
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire ça on voit
Hollande toucher euh toucher ému
bouleversé parce que ça lui ressemble
parce que c'est parce que parce qu'il a
à faire face quand même la chose la plus
difficile de sa vie son tempérament
c'est l'empathie donc et en revanche on
voit aussi Jacques Chirac et son
impassibilité formidable et on est
attentif à Jip disant shirac il encaisse
tout Chirac il bouge pas il ne bouge pas
autant de façon de gérer que de
personnalité que de président Patrice
duamel c'est ça qui est frappant moi ce
qui m'a frappé c'est deux choses d'abord
je trouve que tous les présidents qui
ont été
frappés par ses attentats ENF qui
présidaent pendant que la France a été
frappée ils ont tous remarquablement
bien réagi h euh tous sans exception euh
bien c'est-à-dire avec dignité vous l'
dire oui trouvant les mots qu'il fallait
en prenant les décisions qu'il fallait
et c'est pas évident dans ces périodesl
parce que il faut avoir giscar il avait
une expression il disait dans les temps
de crise faut avoir le les cerveau clair
et les ner d'acier voilà et je pense
qu'ils ont tous su dans ces périodes là
de cerveau clair et les ner
d'acier et la deuxième chose c'est la
recherche alors après c'est un sujet de
débatou de l'unité nationale ce qui est
pas évident et on a vu que au fil du
temps elle s filoché
restons quand même sur ce constat
Dominique r vous qui vous a le plus
marqué peut-être dans ce dans ce
documentaire je pense aussi à Alain Jupé
qui a cette phrase moi je n'avais jamais
vu de cadavre jamais vu vous aussi alors
moi je n'avais jamais vu de cadavre
sanglant ou il ajoute ouis ça c'est ni
de scène de guerre ouais ni de scène de
guerre et et c'est c'est un peu je pense
qu' a ressenti François Hollande parce
que bon il est allé sur les lieux c'est
dit dans le documentaire et moi ce qui
m'a frappé c'est alors tout ce qui a été
déjà je suis d'accord c'est une espèce
de de solidité de dignité et de grande
fragilité de tous euh il ass à ce
momentl il y a même des aveux parfois
manuel Val disant sur les les attentas
multicit euh ça y est on est dedans on
on voyait que ça on avait frappé là on
avait frappé là on savait que c'était
pas fini mais on savait pas ce qu'
allait se passer cette espèce de
d'extraordinaire vérité d'un pouvoir qui
qui est au sommet enfin c'est le pouvoir
c'est eux qui doivent prendre les bonnes
décisions et ils sont pas tout à fait
sûrs d'avoir toute l'information ils
sont dans un moment rare d'authenticité
finalement c'est c'est le c'est le lieu
même du pouvoir on le voit là enfin dans
le RS en font mais c'est c'est
spectaculaire Gérôme cordelier on voit
que c'est l'homme qui est frappé qui est
touché plus que le le le dirigeant le
ministre pour pour prolonger ce que dit
Dominique renier je trouve Queen fait
dans ces dans ces moments on le voit
bien dans votre documentaire c'est que
c'est un peu la quintessence de
l'exercice du pouvoir qui fait c'est la
vérité nue du pouvoir et en même temps
on se dit il faut du sang froid il faut
montrer de la l'empathie de la
compassion h que ce sont des êtres
humains quand mêmes sont pas des robots
l'expression Laurent fabus dans le film
et en même temps faut agir vite dans
l'urgence et sous pression médiatique
donc je trouve qu'il y a une espèce de
cocktail
qui c'est un peu la quintessence de
l'exercice politique et la pression
médiatique ça c'est important parce que
il y a une il y a une césure on explique
dans le documentaire que sur le tent
copernique giscar a été critiqué parce
qu'il est pas venu sur place mais
Pompidou lui il a pas eu d'attentat
spectaculaire mais de go a eu l'OAS bien
évidemment euh jusqu'à Giscard Copernic
les présidents ils n'allaient pas sur
des des drames terroristes ou autre au
moment de Copernic il y a pas encore les
chaînes d'info mais on sent bien que il
y a une pression
médiatique après après il pas question
que les présidents n'y aillent pas
immédiatement Michel coté est-ce que
François Mitterant crée un précédent il
ouvre la voix quand il se déplace sur
les lieux d'un attentat puis ensuite il
assiste à un office religieux juif là il
crée il crée quelque chose de nouveau
dans la façon de gérer
oui oui je pense que euh il est en tout
cas le seul et on peut prévoir que le
service de sécurité lui a dit n'y allz
pas c'est pas le moment euh sûement
d'ailleurs parce que les les présidents
de la réuique ça doit gêner les services
de sécurité parce qu'ils peuvent pas
faire leur leur travail pendant qu'ils
sont là enfin il y était avec C densité
particulière et et l'office religieux
est sûrement important parce qu'on on
comprend que c'est un attentat antijuif
et par conséquent ça rappelle d'autres
choses dans l'histoire française quand
même la génération miteran aussi he mais
il a pris un risque à beouthin on sent
je trouve c'estd la génration c'est comm
miteran il est quand il vient c'est le
premier à aller surent il vient aussi
avec ce qu'il est ce qui est sa
génération ceux qui ont vécu la guerre
ce qui CH Oui marqué par la libération
cette espèce de c'est c'est c'est le
premier attentat c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui qui qui je pense je sais rien
mais je pense la toucher directement
parce que c'est la question de savoir si
ça redémarre ou pas en quelque sorte on
constate aussi une vraie solitude he
dans dans la façon de gérer ce ces
attentats la solitude du président face
à ce face à ce drame miteron va le gérer
très seul d'ailleurs sans faire trop
appel à à son au reste du gouvernement
et il va le gérer seul ils sont seuls
les présidents quand mais François
Hollande quand il revient
des le soir des attentats de de novembre
donc voilà euh il on on on on voit que
il est arrivé à l'Élysée il va y avoir
un conseil des ministres exceptionnel où
il a eu lieu juste avant où il aura lieu
juste après autour de minuit il prend la
parole on sent bien qu'il sort pas d'une
réunion où il y avait 50 conseillers en
communication il est tout seul il
d'après ce que on croit savoir il
improvise euh mais il y a un mélange de
de d'émotions très très fortes et en
même temps le qu'est-ce qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'il faut dire à ce moment-là
pour ne pas trop faire peur au
télpectateur dit Nicolas sarzi là juste
après la tuerie de Toulouse au fond ils
ne peuvent pas rassurer ils ne peuvent
pas garantir que notre ad c'est une
phrase intéressante ouais ouais peut pas
rassurer ou
d' Sarkozi dit ça très bien SAR dit ça
très bien il dit qu'est-ce qu'on dit
quoi comment on les rassure c'est pas
rassurable on peut pas rassurer pas
rassurer et à la fois faut pas faire
peur alors c'est quand même difficile il
faut l'Union nationale et euh et on
n'est pas sûr de l'avir il faut lancer
des lancer des signes enfin des symboles
on n'est pas sûr de trouver le bon ils
sont ils sont vraiment confrontés à une
multitude de questions euh et et il y en
a un qui le dit très bien aussi dans
votre film c'est Laurent fabus si vous
voulez bien on l'écoute ça dure une
trentaine de secondes et on en parle
juste
après la question du terrorisme c'est
est-ce que toutes les mesures ont été
prises est-ce qu'on a suffisamment
anticipé est-ce qu'on
a été suffisamment ferme est-ce que
notre diplomatie correspond à ce qu'il
faut faire est-ce que nous avons eu les
contacts suffisants avec X avec Y et en
même temps il faut laisser la place pour
ce que j'appelais le toucher la
sensibilité le l'émotion le terrain
sinon vous êtes un ordinateur qui se
trompe
oui ne pas sembler robot ou ordinateur
Dominique Ren surtout pas oui c'est
c'est c'est vraiment ce passage est
excellent parce que la chute est
remarquable de vérité aussi c'est-à-dire
que il n demeure pas moins que tous les
dispositifs n'empêcheront pas qu'il faut
une appréhension euh et qu'il faut bien
quand on prend une décision à un moment
donné on se jette dans dans le vide euh
il y a aucune machine qui va vous dire
faut faire ça et ça et votre
documentaire montre très bien je trouve
euh et et d'ailleurs les interview V le
disent eux même et c'est frappant moi ça
m'a beaucoup marqué euh il montre bien
que sur des choses aussi graves que ça
euh le pouvoir qui est complètement
mobilisé avec des personnalités de
qualité qui font aussi bien que possible
et bien ne peuvent pas non plus
énormément de choses c'est-à-dire que
bon d'impuissance au maximum de ce qu'on
peut faire et quand on regarde ça c'est
un peu quand comme quand on vous dit tu
sais il faut grandir Père Noël ça
n'existe pas la vérité elle est dure
elle est dure d'où la phrase aussi de
Sarkozi là et François Hollande dans
cette déclaration vers vers minuit le le
novembre il dit d'ailleurs il explique
lui-même que c'est peut-être pas
fini ça continue de
se que ça avait commencé donc au stade
puis aprèsès spectaculaire
qume sait pas encore exactement ce qui
va se passer dans les dans les heures
qui vont suivre le doute et puis il y a
aussi la culpabilité qui apparaît dans
les dans les discours et c'est normal
notamment dans le discours de Laurent
fabus c'est parce qu'on a permis qu'un
attentat se produise sur le sol français
et donc on a c'est un échec pour le
permis non mais on n pas réussi à voilà
donc uneabilité qui apparaît aussi
beaucoup dans les dans les inter je
trouve qu'il y a un télescopage de de la
la au sein de la fonction présidentielle
de père de la nation chef de guerre donc
tout ça ce il y a une espèce d'alliage
qui se fait dans un moment où évidemment
c'est la vérité d'un homme vous l'avez
tous très bien dit euh qui s'exprime
donc on on là on enfin vous avez dit
saut dans le vide c'est c'est ça il y a
un saut dans le vide et et donc c'est
c'est c'est c'est une vérité c'est un
moment de vérité c'est un électrochoc
pour la nation c'est aussi un
électrochoc à mon avis pour le pour le
chef de la
nation il doit transmettre ce ce cette
émotion c'estd il doit prendre l'émotion
collective et incarner en fait une
émotion collective et en même temps
montrer que il a du sang froid et que
c'est aussi un chef qui est à la
manœuvre et qui va pas se laisser
dépasser et ce que vous disiez c'était
très intéressant sur la la la tragédie
dur moi ce que j'ajouterai juste par
rapport à tous les attentats c'est le
côté inédit c'est-à-dire que quand
François Hollande prend la parole il
sait pas comment ça va se passer c'est
c'est quand même la première fois qu'on
a un attentat d'une telle
ampleur enfin à chaque fois c'est quand
même des moment inédit avec une vérité
totalement mouvante et une tragédie qui
se joue en direct avec des codes qu'ils
n'ont pas forcément de manière
traditionnelle je trouve que le seul qui
réagit de manière très particulière
c'est le général de Gaulle je veux dire
on le voit d'abord il met tout de suite
son uniforme parce que il se veut chef
de guerre et ensuite franchement quand
il dit je dis bien tous les moyens il y
a pas la trace d'une émotion quelconque
dans le général de goule et on sait
qu'en effet il emploiré tous les moyens
lui S il en avait eu d'autres évidemment
mais enfin il se démarquent des autres
présidents de la République il y a
quelque chose qu'on a pas encore abordé
mais qui semble de plus en plus
important après chaque attentat c'est
l'emploi des mots terrorisme que
l'opinion semble attendre elle veut
qu'on mette les mots sur les choses et
qu'on dise pas juste attaque ou et que
très vite le mot terrorisme soit pron
qu'on le qualifie et qu'on
qualifieurence terrorisme islamiste
exactement de plus l'importance des mots
dans ces momentsl ça rassure oui ou en
tout cas ça sûr ça fait peur aussi ça en
partie je pense aussi que le mot excuse
euh en partie euh le fait que ça se soit
passé parce qu'on peut pas empêcher oui
euh on en empêche beaucoup mais c'est
tellement facile pour quelqu'un de faire
exploser quelque chose ou d'assassiner
avec un poignard un professeur ou que
sais-je ou un prêtre et cetera que il y
a aussi une compréhension je trouve de
on fait vraiment le maximum mais on peut
pas de toute façon sinon vous n'auriez
plus aucune liberté vous seriez étouffé
c'est c'est les deux je trouve mais ce
choix de mots vient s'ajouter à la
multitude de questions que les
dirigeants doivent se poser et pour le
coup peut-être aussi les collaborateurs
autour il faut que tu dises ça il faut
que tu dises terrorisme islamiste il
l'ont exprimé ce cette cette question du
choix des mots dans ce moment les
collaborateurs en tout cas on même pas
eu le temps pratiquement pas eu le temps
de de de parler dans C cas le Président
il est vraiment tout seul le lendemain à
la rigueur on fait des phrases mais sur
le moment il y a quelque chose de
relativement unanime qui se dégage du
discours de tous les présidents et
ministres que vous avez interrogé dans
ce documentaire c'est que face au
terrorisme il y a une unité nationale
qui se met en place est-elle réelle ou
fantasmée et de plus en plus fantasmée
on va en parler juste après ce nouvel
extrait écoutez je ne pense pas
voyez-vous que les oppositions quel
qu'ell soi se déchaînent sur le
président lorsqu'il Estace au terrorisme
ce n'est pas
vrai en général les gens savent se tenir
toute famille politique confondu dans ce
genre de circonstances là encore il faut
éviter de se faire des hommes politique
une image trop dégradée
euh l'intérêt national prévut et
quelques secondes après Jean-Pierre
rafarin ajoute sur ce sujet rien ne peut
nous diviser notre force en France c'est
que la réponse c'est l'unité nationale
après après l'attentat de Nice ou la
polémique a démarré euh ah oui presque
le soir même hein voilà elle s'est
développé le lendemain la les mesures de
sécurité n'étaient pas suffisantes
c'était le 14 juillet normalement et
cetera il y aurait dû avoir tel ou
tel conflit communeétat un conflit
police municipale police nationale oui
ou il la fantasme c'est unité nationale
qu'il pense vivre ou voir ou observer
elle a été moi je pense qu'elle a été
réelle et qu'elle s'est délité et
aujourd'hui je crois que ça n'existe
plus hein non pas que ce soit qu'il n'y
ait pas un une opinion majoritaire
mais je pense qu'on a passé on a passé
un cap à partir de quand d'après vous à
quel moment é était-elle réelle et à
partir de quand elle était réelle au
moment au moment desattentat du Bataclan
et du Stade de France effectivement
quand Cho on on voit évidemment
les la foule et les dirigeants
bouleversés on le voit même au plan
européen puisque derrière lui François
Hollande entraîne l'Europe les les
représentants les dirigeants du monde
européen entier mais c'est vrai Cassez
rapidement et ni c'est sûrement un T
enfin la tentamené c'est sûrement un
tournant là-dessus euh ou euh quelqu'un
qui appartenait à l'opposition reproche
et et il y a et il y a aussi vous
parliez des termes par exemple le terme
lou solitaire oui c'est c'est un terme
qui qui correspond peut-être je suis pas
spécialiste du terrorisme c'est pas
parce qu'on a fait ce documentaire mais
euh je sais pas s'il correspond à la
réalité je crois que c'est assez
controversé hein certains disent oui
d'autres disent non en tout cas c'est
c'est c'est c'est assez angoissant pour
les ça veut dire qu'en gros il peut se
passer n'importe quoi à n'importe quel
moment c'est vrai voilà c'est c'est ça
c'est très compliqué sur le l'Union
nationale il a il y a il y a autre chose
je pense c'est quand même que il y a des
expressions comme les fichers s par
exemple il y a un attentat et on apprend
que que le terroriste était fichs et
tout de suite il y a une polémique qui
démarre et là l'unité nationale non
comme il est fiché s il aurait pas dû
être libre de ses mouvements il aurait
dû être sur veill et cetera et cetera on
l'a vu dans le drame récent avec le
malheureux épouvantable assassinat à
race tout de suite on on a dit fichs
tout de suite la polémique est partie
est-ce que ça veut dire que les
oppositions ne respectent même plus ce
moment peut-être de de d'empathie qui
doit exister après un attentat et
ensuite on règle les les problèmes mais
il existe plus ce tempsl dei moi je
dirais que si ça s'observe c'est parce
que la
société ne partage plus mais déjà en
2015 15 avec Charlie Hebdo on a vu
apparaître je ne suis pas Charlie hein
oui alors c'était un peu à bas bruit
puis c'est devenu fort maintenant on le
voit revenir aujourd'hui he donc c'est
c'est resté vous avez essayé de
m'embarquer dans une affaire qui n'est
pas la mienne avec toute une série de
branchements idéologiqu et religieux
mais c'est la société elle-même qui
s'est modifié et qui s'est voilà
recomposé sous forme de communauté aussi
il faut dire que ce qui s'est modifié
aussi c'est qu'on assiste dans dans
notre film à la naissance du terrorisme
islamique parce que pendant très
longtemps ce n'est pas du terrorisme
islamique c'est terrorisme de
l' après au fond l'attentat de Toulouse
Sarkozi le dit est le le premier des
attentats islamiques et donc à partir de
là la chose change de nature parce qu'à
partir de là on peut rien faire contre
n'importe quel terrorisme peut-être mais
les fichiers ils sont pour la plupart
des islamistes donc oui puis la
répétition des attentats fait que
l'opinion hlass et qu'elle en a
peut-être assez qu'elle ne veut plus
entendre par
I a qui oui enfin aussi on est dans un
contexte particulier aujourd'hui avec
une très forte dégradation du débat
public hein et donc les oppositions bon
c'est c'est ce qu'on voit à l'Assemblée
nationale avec la France insoumise et
tout donc et puis le fait que maintenant
il y a des on le voit bien récemment
hein toutes les lignes rouges sont
franchies par des gens sur les réseaux
sociaux où on on a l'impression qu'il a
il y a plus beaucoup de de enfin il y a
certaines personnes qui n'ont plus du
tout de boussole intime hein donc euh a
plus inéressant vous parliez des réseaux
sociaux effectivement qui VT sûement
changé la donne dans cette idée d'unité
nationale maisi je veux témoigner comme
comme chacun était témoin de loin euh de
mars 2012 ouais
euh l'attentat de Toulouse aux aratora
voilà chacun sait que c'est la première
fois depuis 1945 que des enfants sont
tués parce que Juifs ouis donc
l'événement est énorme moi à ce
moment-là euh j'ai pensé et ça m'est
arrivé de le dire dans des émissions euh
je ne vois pas comment l'élection peut
avoir lieu oui ça me paraissait colossal
rappelons qu'à ce momentlà la campagne
est suspendue oui aujourd'hui encore
aujourd'hui encore je peux vous dire que
je ne comprends pas que la campagne a
repris son cours je n'en reviens pas
qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire qu'est-ce
que vous voulez qu'est-ce que vous je
veux dire qu'il y a deux choses il y a
premièrement le fait que ni ni le
président Sarko ni ni l'opposition ni le
gouvernement je crois le pays n'a pas pu
prendre conscience de ce qui s'est passé
pas pris la mesure c'est pas possible on
peut pas donc on fait comme si il y a eu
un événement un accident d'autocar et
puis on continue après et puis ensuite
je me dis B c'est quand même le
président qui est là-dedans le futur
président qui est pas loin on va le
savoir plus tard et et au fond ils sont
pris et je sais je sais pas pour mettre
en cause ils sont pris dans une
incapacité commune que que beaucoup
avaient à l'époque de ne pas pouvoir
évaluer le moment la dimension morale
historique du moment la gravité euh et
donc eux-mêmes sont saisis par la
surprise de cette de ce choc et et nous
sommes tous comme cela et c'est un peu
le propre des attentats je trouve et
bien ça par exemple Emmanuel Val
manemmanuel vas dans le dans le
documentaire il
dit le 14 juillet 2016 donc Nice ça a
été un basculement oui et ben moi je
crois qu'il a raison parce que
bizarrement dans l'esprit
public quand on va même un homme seul
sans réseau tout ce que très bien
François Hollande si je me trompe pas
c'est lui qui dit
[Musique]
ça
on a visé ce jour-là a que c'est en 14
juillet en quelque sorte la France de
tous les jours qui se balade avec les
enfants et cetera et donc comment
voulez-vous faire voyez il y a cette
idée que quand même il y a des
situations on se met un peu en danger
bon là qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire
c'est vraiment et du coup je pense que
c'est ça aussi qui a fait naître un peu
la polémique à l'époque c'est que on
ressentait que décidément c'était
vraiment tout le monde partout même en
ayant une vie très ordinaire pour le
dire ainsi parce que ça c'est parfois ce
type de de choses qu'on a à l'esprit
dans l'opinion et c'est bien normal euh
et donc c'était beaucoup plus important
euh que euh on a pu le dire c pas c'est
pas un de plus c'est quelque chose
singulier c'est un peu comme ce qui
s'est passé la préfecture de police
c'était pas le sujet mais c'est le
pèreamel chose comme ça voyez ou pati ça
pti c'est c'est des événements qui en
eux-mêmes euh nous font franchir des
étapes supplémentaires dans dans
l'inquiétude encord deier oui en fait
c'est une succession de basculement
parce que vous avez Toulouse 2012
Toulouse enfin voilà des enfant euh
parce que juif
euh tu es à bout touchant enfin c'est
incroyable he cette petite fille tirée
par les cheveux enfin voilà après le
Bataclan là aussi c'est inédit euhon a
des Anglais évidemment c'est inédit mais
à chaque fois c'est inéit en mais mais
pour le coup c'est peut-être au zaratora
peut-être l'exemple d'une mauvaise
gestion politique de de de l'attentat
vous disiez tout à l'heure ils ont à peu
près tous bien géré ils ont eu les B les
mots justes c'est collectivement estce
que finalement en 2012 il y a pas une
erreur politique de pas prendre la
mesure de on attend on arrête on peut
pas collectivement le problème c'est que
ces attentats banalisent la violence et
et l'horreur en fait c'est-à-dire que
maintenant les gens sont quand même
abreuvés d'images enfin il y a il y a il
y a encore 20 ans on aurait imaginez ces
imagesl euh benah c'est c'est c'est
quand même des images terribles et on le
voit d'ailleurs enfin pardon sous nos
yeux aussi hein je dire le l'attentat
enfin l'attaque terroriste du Hamas avec
les images qui sont qui circule sur les
réseaux sociaux et ben sur les réseaux
sociaux elles sont peu
édulcoré sur les chaînes de télévision
elles sont
heureusement même savoir quelles sont je
sais pas qui autour de cette table les a
vu mais c'est totalement insoutenable
c'est insupportable c'est pas
regardableardable c'est une violence
quand même qui arrive comme ça et qui
maintenant n'a plus de de filtre en fait
il y a quelque chose mais je dire une
banalité mais sous le contrôle du grand
politologue
euh moi je je pense vraiment encore une
fois c'est c'est une badalité HE pardon
et que depuis le début des années 2000
dans l'addition entre le l'éruption des
chaînes d'info et le la montée en
puissance des réseaux sociaux le paysage
politique en général il change
complètement parce que les citoyens
deviennent des acteurs politiques et
quand il y a des événements comme cela
c'est c'est pas du tout la même chose un
attentat il y en a eu où on avait des
inf formation à 13h à 20h à la radio et
puis le moment où vous voyez absolument
tout ça change totalement la perception
ce sentiment de sidération par exemple
les Twin Towers le sentiment de
sidération si on avait pas vu le l'avion
rentrait dans la dans la tour c'était ça
c'était une catastrophe effrayante
épouvantable mais il y aurait pas eu le
même la même réaction à l'échelle
mondiale ça change dans dans la gestion
par les par les présidents c'est c'est
c'est c'est c'est à la fois euh beaucoup
plus compliqué parce que le moindre fait
geste et cetera le moindre mot et euh en
même temps sur le terrain de
l'information il y a peut-être moins à
dire parce que les gens voient les
images eux-mêmes donc la description est
pas forcément utile donc ça change la G
je persuadé que quand même ça a un effet
profond dans le euh le sentiment de euh
d'inquiétude généralisé et dans la
mauvaise la mauvaise humeur des Français
parce que c'est multiplié peut-être que
les gens n'ont pas vu les images mais
ils savent que d'autres les ont vu il y
il y a une accumulation de tension qui
là me me semble
vraiment vraiment enfin importante
aujourd'hui il fait il y a un passage
très intéressant qui fait le lien avec
ce qu'on vient de dire à l'instant c'est
lorsque Jean-Louis Debray évoque la
présence des équipes de télévision hm hm
euh ralette kcal avant
l'arrivée euh des des forces de l'ordre
et qui ont gêné en fait
l'action et et cette j'ai trouvé que
c'était je savais pas ce fait moi je
connaissais pas mais j'ai trouvé que
c'était une anticipation de ce que nous
vivons aujourd'hui mais ça a été la même
chose sur l'hyper cacher ouais c'est
ça parce que il y avait il y avait les
gens qui regard la police a fait savoir
aux chaînes d'information que il y avait
des images qu'il fallait pas montrer
quoi
comme terrorist à l'intérieur de l'hyach
il avait un petit écran où il regardait
sur son
Ione les médias et les chaîninos se sont
fait recadrer hein à l'époque non mais
ça change toute la gestion
deoption juste ajouter ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui parce que ça s vu
récemment ça c'était le cas pour Mohamed
mer et c'était le cas le 7 octobre
2023 les terroristes ont une GoPro oui
ça veut dire que si vous êtes chef de
l'État vous savez pas si vous allez pas
recevoir une vidéo ou terrible euh
produite par le terroriste lui-même
diffusé par ses réseaux parce qu'ils
utilisent énormément ça c'était très
juste ce que vous disiez on a fait nous
une une analyse chronologique du
terrorisme outre quantitatif mais sur
ces modalités de diffusion et même de
recrutement euh c'est l'explosion les
réseaux sociaux hein le web et les
réseaux sociaux c'est c'est l'explosion
TikTok est un un espace de recrutement
considéraable et cetera et donc ils ont
la maîtrise de la communication en
quelque sorte ce qui est inédit dans
l'histoire du qui change pour les chef
d'État chaque fois c'est plus compliqué
alors après laassidération et l'émotion
vient aussi pour le président face au
terrorisme le temps de l'action
politique législative institutionnelle
et là aussi la situation peut être
délicate en 2015 c'est François Hollande
qui se prend les pieds dans le tapis si
vous me permettez l'expression il
revient dans votre film sur sa
proposition de déchéance de nationalité
on
l'écoute la déchéance de nationalité qui
je rappelle existe dans notre droit et
et qui était élargi uniquement pour les
crimes de terroristes cette disposition
qui finalement avait été saluée par le
Congrès tout entier et bien il y a eu un
débat qui s'est introduit et et
souvent de bonne foi ceux qui pensaient
qu'on remettait en cause le droit de la
nationalité mais donc quand j'ai vu
queil y avait cette somme
d'incompréhension de surencher de de
raccourciis je sais pas ce qu'il faut
dire en tout cas malentendu entretenu
délibérément j'ai préféré retirer ça
pour assurer le consensus quelle
conclusion faut-il en tirer quand on est
du côté du pouvoir pas de prise de
décision à chaud c'est ça l'idée c'est
qu'il faut réfléchir d'abord que c'était
pas bien préparé ouais mais ça ne peut
pas l'être bah quand même un petit peu
quand même quand on quand on jette ça
dans le dans le débat public il vaut
mieux quand même un peu réfléchir un peu
en amont plutôt que de prendre l'opinion
à témoins enfin voilà c'est compliqué qu
même c'est extraordinairement compliqué
parce que moi je pense que François
Holland il a eu raison de faire ce
discours au Congrès parce que
l'événement était tellement énorme et
effrayant et anxiogène pour les Français
qu'il fallait un geste politique et le
fait de s'adresser en congrès tous les
parlementaires c'était voilà mais c'est
c'est vrai moi je me souviens j'ai
regardé comme beaucoup en
direct et à la sortie des parlementaires
il y en a très très peu qui ont dit la
déchance de nationalité c'est pas
possible c'est une poignée et après ça
n' été dit que par troues pris par ses
propres troupes le problème c'est que ça
s dit et là c'est embêtant pour un
président de la République ça a été dit
surtout par euh Olivier fort et toute la
toute la la bande des gens qui
contestaient déjà à
l'intérieur du parti socialiste donc au
fond on a l'impression que c'est un un
mouvement intrinsèque intérieur au Parti
socialiste qui a mis Hollande dans cette
situation président socialiste il y
avait une nécessité de faire ce JIR
d'annonce c'estàd un acte fort oui
l'opinion le demandait pouvez pas faire
des cérémonies puis dire et ça va
recommencer après on en fera une autre
d'un genre différent il faut des actes
c'était ça la réponse et vous pouvez pas
dire ça va faire monter le FN à l'époque
le RN aujourd'hui si vous faites rien
pour que ça monte pas trop donc et là il
est pris dans une situation moi je le
trouve abandonné en fait dans sa Parole
là hein il s'est retrouvé en fait il
était dans le sens de l'opinion à coup
sûr euh et pour des raisons
il est très bon Jeanpierre chevenem dans
ce qu' dit à ce momentl Paris tradition
de la gauche une certaine gauche qui ne
peut pas admettre la répression et qui
du coup empêche à une autre gauche de
gouvernement de tenir de bien gouverner
et puis aussi d'illeurs d'être réélu
quoi d'Illes qu'est-ce qui se serait
passé au fond François Hollande perd son
élection sur
ce sur ce thème là sur la dé de
nationalité la dé de nationalité pourant
il est en Phe avec l'opinion nous dit
ben voilà peut-être qu'il aurait dû
tenir bon peuttre qu'il auraitir B une
clé pour être réélu ça ou c'est ça je
crois qu' il jouent sa réélection en
disant la démission de Christian tobira
il y a eu les fondeurs et la démission
de la garde des S quand même dans cette
période nous am quand même à cette
question de comment faire des annonces
qui soient fortes et sécurisantes
comment faire des annonces qui soient
fortes et sécurisantes pour l'opinion
sont Ren sur la liberté publique et il
est là le dilemme aussi du responsable
politique ou ben il y a des moments
peut-être où on peut
s'approcher d'une certaine réalité
politique et réagir par des il peuvent
être extraordina du général de Gaulle
que rappelait Michel tout à l'heure je
dis bien tous les moyenss bien ce que ça
veut dire la dure précise d'ailleurs
ouite avec avec un petit oui oui oui les
services secrets les réseaux et toutes
les sortes de réseau Dom vous pensez que
l'opinion serait prête à Rener sur ses
propres libertés ah sans aucun doute oui
y compris dans l'inconscience mais sans
aucun doute surtout dans la conscience
non mais parce que vous pouvez pas vous
pouvez pas demander à des citoyens
ordinaires et c'est pas péjoratif du
tout de ne pas trouver
inacceptable qu'on puisse comme ça
écraser autant de personnes le 14
juillet et cetera et que ça peut vous
arriver arriver au votre et CEA donc
vous demandez des actes et si on vous
explique c'est compliqué du point de vue
de ceci ou de cela et c'est souvent vrai
ça ne fait pas une justification donc là
là la la question est d'arriver à placer
ces mesures exceptionnelles sous un
régime de contrôle et éventuellement
d'ailleurs de de de durée provisoire
permettant de les relâcher ou de revenir
à des situations moins moins moins moins
moins moins moins contraintte si les
choses semblent s'améliorer prenez
l'opération sentinelle oui il y en a eu
jusqu'à 10000 he militaire dans les rues
un président arrive dit je vais mettre
l'armée dans les rues et cetera c'est un
tolé absolument épouvantable mais là les
gens ils ont été rassurés dans les
gardes dans les aéroports dans les
grands lieux public de voir des
militaires
armés dit c'est une honte qu'on a
demandé à l'armée de d'invenir donc ça
dit quelque chose du décalage entre la
classe politique les problématiques
inter pas été très contesté par par le
milieu politique que ça dit et ce sera
ma dernière question que finalement le
responsable politique le président le
prinistre son gouvernement manque
d'outils pour répondre au terrorisme
est-ce qu'on çap nous som en démocratie
nous sommes en démocratie tout de même
donc est-ce qu'on pense que le modèle
démocratique est préférable à un modèle
plus plus unique et plus populaire
mais oui moi je je pense que les gens
attendent et que la démocratie de temps
en temps doit se doter d'outil qu'elle
dont elle ne se doute dont elle se ne
choisirait pas qu'elle ne choisirait pas
dans des période plus calme ça me paraît
la moindre remise en cause de la
démocratie Dominique rier je crois quand
même qu'il a des il y a un problème
d'outil en effet je suis d'accord et il
me semble que l'outil européen devrait
être bien plus puissant qu'il ne l' il
est quasiment inexistant c'est une
grande faute collective et puis a un
problème de de je sais pas si c'est dire
de de forme d'esprit de volonté de de
caractère
euh non parce que nous avons des
générations de gouvernants qui sont qui
sont maintenant très éloignés des
grandes crises historiques violentes des
guerres et cetera qui n'ont pas ça en
héritage et qui peut-être ne se sentent
pas à l'aise dans le fait d'engager la
force directement et de de mener un vrai
combat au sens militaire et et là c'est
quelque chose qui doit changer parce
qu'il faut se r mais moralement aussi
pas simplement juridiquement Jérôme
cordelier moi je pense qu'il y a quand
même eu des choses qui ont été faites
puisque il y a quand même beaucoup
d'attentats qui qui encore déjoués et
donc il y a eu quand même une évolution
y compris du droit dans le cette
maîtrise voilà mais la grande difficulté
je pense c'est que ce sont les les
terroristes sont très innovants et
surtout bénéficient de plus de souplesse
d'action que une vieille démocratie avec
ses lourdeurs institutionnelles c'estes
ces procédure c'estes débats politiques
c'estes débats internes à la politique
sa vie
publique où on conteste un peu tout donc
donc tout ça c'est c'est compliqué pour
une vieille démocratie de de de faire
face à quelque chose qui est une réalité
mouvante et souvent après qui dépasse un
peu ce qu'on avait déjà prévu dans un
temps récent quoi Patrice diamel pour
conclure moi ce qui me frappe dans ces
si on reprend alors de Gaulle il est
hors y compris quand il met son
uniforme difficilement à
fairer t les autr mais tous les autres
il y a ce qu'on il y a ils interviennent
à mon avis tous très bien on l'a dit
tout à l'heure euh il y a ce qu'on
appelle un effet drapeau hein les
sondages qui montent 10 points 15 points
et cetera mais la rapidité avec laquelle
l'opinion oublie c'està-dire 2 mois
après ils reviennent à leur à leur code
de popularité précédente et moi qui fait
partie de ceux qui pensent que on
critique beaucoup tr trop les dirigeants
politiques je trouve que franchement on
mesure pas alors ils ont été candidats à
élection présidentielle ils ont été élus
bon voulait Il voulaient être président
très bien mais on ne mesure pas
l'incroyable poids de responsabilité qui
pèse sur leur fond c'est pour ça qu'on a
fait cette série absolument ah ben alors
merveilleux ça ça ça vient clôturer
notre débat de façon magnifique merci
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à cette émission et merci à
vous de nous avoir suivi comme chaque
semaine à très vite sur public sén à
bienô
[Musique]